2 and warrington is to move into tier 3
coronavirus
restrictions the very high alert level
from one minute past midnight tonight
tuesday morning
at the hell secretary matt hancock had
briefed the comments last week that
discussions were underway
with local leaders in warrington and it
has been confirmed
today that warrington is to move into
tier three what does that mean
well it means people must not socialize
with anybody they don't live with or
have not formed a support bubble within
any
indoor setting in any private garden
or at most hospitality venues outdoors
and in at ticketed
events people must not socialize in a
group of more than six in an
outdoor public space such as a park or
beach the countryside a public garden
or a sports venue in terms of
hospitality all pubs and bars that don't
serve food must close any alcohol must
be served alongside
a substantial meal people should try to
avoid traveling
outside of the very high alert level or
entering a very high alert level other
than for
essential purposes betting shops adult
gaming centers casinos
and soft play centers are to close
as well a funding package of 1.68
million pounds as well as 4.2 million
pounds in business support
funding has been agreed the health
secretary matt hancock has said
infection rates are rising in warrington
we've agreed with local leaders that
it's time
to take action i know these measures
will mean sacrifices must be made by the
people in warrington
and i want to extend my thanks to each
and every one of them for recognizing
the severity of the situation
and sticking to the rules please
remember now is the time for us all to
work together
and get this virus under control